あの 今 まあ瞑想するということで
まあサティの実践なんですけどね
サティというのは まあ一つ一つ体に起こる現象を気づくことなんですね
いわゆる私がこのよく言う
この まあ全部実況中継してみると
実況中継してみるということは
まあ本当は我々のその瞬間瞬間の経験なんですね
痛みであろうか 膨らみであろうか
そういういろんな経験
ずっと心が経験していくんです
で 経験というのは まあ単なるこの感受
感覚というかね 感覚だけなんですね
そこに何かあるわけじゃなくて
単なる感覚だけであって
この感覚に経験というんですね
で 本当は随分単純なことなんです
ものすごい単純なことなんです
で 痛いと痛みと確認する
もうそれ単なる経験でしょう
痛みというのは 体で感じる一つの経験なんですね
膨らみということも体で感じる一つの経験なんです
縮みということも同じこと
で まあ妄想というのも
やっぱりまあそれも感覚なんですね
感覚がないと妄想することもできないんです
いろいろ感覚があって楽しいやら苦しいやら悔しいやら
まあそういうのは妄想として出てくるんですね
怒りやらもう もう何か
ですからその楽しいとかね
まあ苦しいとか怒りとか欲とかっていうのは
この心の感覚みたいなもんなんですね
まあそういうものはこの実況してみる
なぜ実況するかというと
この世の中で 自分って何なのかっていうことは
このまあ 一旦この まあ宗教を発展していく過程でね
まあ考え出したもので
まあ自分って何なのかっていうことは
本当はこのインド宗教なんですね
考えたのは で 他の宗教ではそんなに細々したことを考えてないんです
ただ人が死んじゃったらどうかいっていうこととかね
で 人は神様が作ったと
それぐらいで終わってるんです
自分って何なのかと考えたのはインドなんですけど
そこでまあいろんな宗教が出てきて
うーん いろんなことをやはり言い始めたんですね
生命ってこういうものだとかね
で そういうことだから
自分で何なのかということは科学的に見てほしい
単なる信仰ではなくて
インド宗教から見れば
あの 人間にはこの実体たる魂があります
で その実体たる魂があると
いきなり決めつけちゃったんですね
魂があるのは当たり前
あっぱれ 証拠出す必要はないと
それから考えたのは その魂はどのようなものか
そこでそれはある人々は魂は永遠ですよ
ある人々は  やっぱり永遠と言ったっても永遠じゃないと
いわゆるこの有限 無限ではなくて
永遠というか有限 無限ですね
魂が無限にもう死なないという
ある人々は魂は有限であると
有限でいた人々の中でもいろいろいます
一人のグループの宗教家が
もう魂がもうずっとあるんだけど
人が死ぬと魂も死ぬんだと
それで終わりと だから有限ですよ
そこはインドではこのインド
インドの唯物論なんですね
唯物論はインドにありましたね
唯識論と同じで唯物論
で またある人々はそうじゃなくて
魂が人が死んでも死ぬんじゃなくて
もっと高い次元にどこかに行って
まあそこで生きていて
またそこで死んじゃうんだと
そういう概念になったところで
まあそんなどこまでの次元に伸びるかということを考え出したりして
そこでまあもう光年単位で光年単位でね
もう何光年 何光年ぐらいかも死んじゃう
で それから魂の将来はそう語るんだったら
魂の過去も語らなくちゃいけないんですね
魂はどのように生まれたんですかと
そこで唯物論の人々というのは
まあこの世の中で生命の誕生とともに魂が現れちゃって
現れて死ぬと死んじゃう
で 将来もあるんだという人々は
やっぱり故に過去もあるんだということになって
だが 過去にも魂が無限でもうずっとあったという人もいて
ある日突然生まれたと
という人々もいる それで魂に対するもう過去についてもいろんなことを語る
それで魂のこの性質 特色
そういうふうにいろんなことを言う教えもいろいろあります
で そういう魂に対するいろんな宗教で言っていたことっていうのは
僕 一応あの我論として
我論の説としてもまとめてはいるんですね
でもみんなにあった一つの問題は
まあアプライオリとしてアプライオリっていうか
日本語で何か日本語の言葉ありますかね
前提としてもう証拠いらない
まあ認めているんですね
ただ 魂があるかないかっていう質問がしないんです
魂はどのようにものですか？という質問なんですね
それが それですごく喧嘩しちゃうんですね
魂の広げるスペクトルというのを
だからそれをしゃべるんですよ
だから魂が例えば無限であるならば
大きさ どれくらい大きいかと
これは大変な問題なんですね
そこでものすごい小さいという人々もいて
これはまあ無限大に広げるんだという人々もいるんですね
大きさもあるんだったら
やっぱり色がなければね
魂は何色ですか？そこで魂には七つの色ついてるんです
だから 人によって魂の色が変わるんです
そういうふうな もう膨大な宗教哲学っていうのは
このかなり 膨大ですよ
インドにはありますからね
そこは誰一人にもこの納得いける
納得できる答えは見つからなかったんです
みんなものすごい真面目にすごい考えていたんだけど
一旦インドで残ったのは
この魂と物質が同一のものだという教えなんですね
体と魂は同一のものである
で 体 物質でしょ で 同じものだと
それから物質と魂が同一であるならば
他の物質も魂なんですよ
そういうことで すべてがすべては魂そのものというふうな教えは残ってしまって
他の教えはどんどんわからなくなって消えてしまったんですね
で そこで自分の体も外にある建物やら地球やら
もうなんだかんだ物質なものを全て魂であるならば
なんでそれはその通りにわからへんかということで
まあそれはもう無明だからと
まあマヤという言葉使ってますけど
仏教で無明って言葉使う
だからわからないだけであって
修行すればわかりますよと
そこで物質の魂が物質化になったところで
結構苦しんじゃうんですね
壊れたりもしますしね
年取ったりもするし ですから魂は頑張って物質の次元から非物質の次元
あるいは純粋な魂の次元に成長させればいいんじゃないかなとか考えたりする
まあ考え方はそれなりにはなるほどとわかるかもしれませんだけど
みんな基本的なところで大きな間違いを起こしてるんですね
この魂があると決めたところで
どのように決めたんですかと
だから魂は細長いか バカでかくて太くて長いかって決める前に
あるかないか だからあるかないかとわからないものについて語るものは全て妄想なんです
だから我々にとってペガサスについて語れるでしょ
皆様画用紙を持ってきて
じゃあペガサスの絵を描いてくださいと頼んだら
みんなそれぞれ自分の能力で描くでしょ
絵は上手な人はすごい立派なペガサスを描く
下手な人はまあもう馬か牛か豚かわからないんだけど
何かを描く でもみんな何か描く
だからあるかないかわからないんだから
どんなペガサスが正しくて
どんなペガサスが間違ってるかと言えますか？言えませんでしょ
例えば まあこれがこれペガサスですよで
まあ一応ペガサスというのは翼がついてる馬ということですからね
で ある人が描いたこれ馬ですか
牛ってどっちですかとわかる
区別できない下手な絵だとすると
でも翼が2つついてる
じゃあこれ間違ってますよと言えますか？言えないんです
立派にまたもう立派に絵の上手な人はものすごいかっこいい馬を描いて
もう飛んでるような形でペガサスのスピードも動きも表して
翼も綺麗に美しく描いて見せたりする
どちらが正しいんですかね
例えば人の顔を描いたら
これダメ これはいいと言えるでしょ
モデルがあるんだから
描いたモデルが 人の顔の場合はマルバツつけます
でも ペガサスの絵を描いてもらうところでマルバツつけることはできません
わかりますか？その論理が
なぜできないかというと
ペガサスがいるかないかっていうのは
証明ないことでしょ そういうことで
魂が長いか短いかとかね
有限か無限かとか何色かとかね
物質と魂が同一のものか
あるいは全く別々なものですかとかね
この六十二種類にいろんな教えを分けて経典でありますけどね
で そこだけじゃなくて
いろんなところで魂について語っているところがあります
魂にいわゆる他の宗教で語っているものをまとめたところがありますけど
どちらがそこまで正しいんですかね
どちらかも言えないし
ですから その人々はお互いに喧嘩するんですね
師匠にまあ論争したりする
だからお釈迦様はこの人々の論争について語ったのは
自分が思ったことは正しいと思ってるんだからそうなるんですよと
だから思考の働きでわかってる人っていうのはね
誰とも喧嘩しないんだ
もう喧嘩相手にならないんですよ
ですから お釈迦様はこの問題を見たところで
問題はもう魂は細長いか太いかというところじゃないんですよ
調べるべきなのは 魂は何なのかっていうことなんですね
そういうものはありますかないかということなんですね
そこでこのお釈迦様は人間の感覚の世界
認識の世界 そこを分析するところで答えは見つかるということなんですね
みんなこれと わかったね
かすかに頭の良い人は一人もいないんだ
まあだから仏教はまあ智慧の世界
智慧の世界 智慧の宗教というね
仏教という言葉に智慧の教えという意味ですからね
それでは残った全ての物質であろうが
自分の精神であろうが
もう全て魂っていう概念は今連鎖しているということであって
このサイババなんかあのあのマジックやってますけど
あれはこの自分の教えにもとづいてやってるんです
だから物質は魂だから魂はもう
なんて言いますか ユニバースで全てのどこにも満遍何とかという仏教用語もありますけども
知っているものだから
ないところはないんです
問題はそれ物質化しているかないかだけなんです
だったら何もないところから物質化すること
することができるという
まあ論理的にそうなりますね
それで最後は私は神ですよということを言うために
もういろんなことを物質化して見せる
問題は あの時計とかね
作るものはね ペンダントとか
あるいは灰 一番たくさん作るの灰なんですね
みんなの こちら額のところに塗るヒンドゥー教の人を灰は物質化するんだけど
時計っていうのは機械だからね
まあ一億個ぐらいね 物質化してくれればね
まあ一光年足すぐらいね
まあ何のこともないんだから
神だからね みんな終わりですよ
誰も何も言えなくなっちゃいますからね
[笑い]でも大勢の人が信仰してるんです
日本でもすごいんです
サイババは信仰している人だ
で あの みんなすごい威張って頭がいいと
まあ向こうは頭がいいというならば
まあうちらは頭が悪いんですけどね
と思いますけど まあとにかく
あのサイババがああいう風に
あのいろいろまじないマジックをやって
人の黙ってることをみんなその通りや
その通りと思うのも ヒンドゥー教の教えに基づいてやってることなんですね
はい いわゆるこの魂が物質化するんだと
魂が物質化して生命になったり
地球になったり 宇宙になったりするんだと
その大乗仏教でもあるのはその考え方なんですね
それは魂と言えないんですけど
仏教の用語です だからそこはあの仏教になって
ブッダになってくると
ブッダがもうそこで基本的な問題があるんだ
まず魂があるかないかと確かめないと
これは細長いか太いかとわからないんだと
まずあるかないか そこで
ものはあると言うために我々は何を使いますか？まあ魂でなくても何かがある X
があるというためには
我々は 何かあればよろしいかと
で その例えば簡単なことで
こちらに部屋があるとする
あると言ったらみんなありますよ
ありますからね 本棚がありますかと
大体はみんな答えがないんだから聞きませんだけど
こちらに本棚がありますかと聞いたら
大体どんな答えが来ると思いますか？どういう答えがね
ありますという答えが来るんですね
だからあるということをそこに成り立つでしょ
なぜそちらに本棚がありますとおっしゃったんですか？見えるからなんですね
わかりやすいんです 目で感じたんだからなんです
そこで外にある暖房は火をつけてますか？ わかりません
いいえ もう普通に答えてください
普通に答える 音が聞こえてるからついてる
ついてるでしょ だから外に暖房がついてます
火が どうやって知ってますかというと
聞こえたんだからなんです
だから前の答えも正しいんですよ
音だけで判断できませんだからね
正しいんだけど 一応推測できますね
なぜならば前見たことがありますね
暖房に火をつけたらこういう音が出るんだという 2つの経験がありましたから
今音だけ聞いてもついてるんだということはわかりますね
そうやってこの部屋は真っ暗にする
何も見えない サブとんがありますかと聞くと答えられますか？ 触って確かめます
だからあると答えられるでしょ
触って答えられますからね
そういうふうなことで
人間があるということを知ってるんです
その器官はいくつありますか？耳で音と
目でそうやって形と 鼻で香りと
舌で味と 体で触ってする硬いとか熱いとか
そういう感覚です それから五感だけじゃなくて
仏教では六感にしているんですね
頭が勝手に回転するんだからね
ですから まあそれはそんなに難しいことじゃないんで
何て言われたって五感だけ語ってるんですよ
わからなくても明確に頭が勝手に回転しているでしょうに
例えばどう思いますかと
何のことなくも聞こえるでしょうに
例えば壁がありますか？ではなくて
この壁はあなたどう思いますか？と
聞こえるでしょ？聞くことできるでしょ
この場合は壁があることは目で見るんであって
それどう？どう思う？と聞くが
それ意識でしょう 六感
六番目の意でしょ 思うこと目で思えませんからね
そうやって六感がある
眼耳鼻舌身意という そこに情報触れ
触れたものは感じる この感じたものを知るんですよ
目で感じて 本棚があると結論づける
耳で感じてストーブは点いていると
まあ結論付けてしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 知ることで あるということが成り立つんであり
そこでこの感覚っていうのはずっと変化する
見るものも変化する ですから
我々はあるということもずっと変化している
他何も見つからない 変化がなければ見えない
聞こえない 味わえない
何も変化しない コンタクトできないんですね
だから我々の認識コンタクトっていうのは無常であるんだから
すべてのものは 例えば何か触ったとする
体に変化が起きなかったならば
わからないんですよ 体に変化起こるんですよ
反応起こるんですよ 起こるんだから
あ あります ありますと言うんですよ
だからありますと言うために必要なのは変化なんですね
だからありますという言葉が浮いてるんです
で なぜ浮いてるかでしょうかね
だから実際に体に何か変化が起きる
その起きた変化でもってあると思うだけ
あるということは証明したわけじゃないんです
ここに本棚があると思ったんです
目で感じたんだから 目で感じたんだからあるというわけでもないんです
目は信頼できないんです
目がちょっとおかしくなったら違うもの見えるんだから
こんなちょっと変化しちゃったらもうとんでもないことになるでしょう
例えば目の中にあるあの液体ありますね
それほんのちょっとでも濁っちゃったら
全部白くかすんで見えたりするでしょう
[笑い]だから我々の視力こそ正しいと言えないんですよ
一応科学的に研究したところでね
他の動物たちに問いとかね
ものすごい視力あるんだとかね
なんで上ものすごい上の空を飛んでるタカとかね
この草の中で動いてるネズミ見つかるんですかね
小さなウサギとかね 同じ色でしょうに
野生のウサギとか真っ白くはないんです
あれもタカが見つかりますよ
タカが止まって見てるわけでもないんですよ
それは動いてるんだから
だからかなり視力ないんです
だからそういう 生命体にどのように見えるかと
またわかったもんじゃないんですよ
そこでこの生命が小さくなると
例えばゴキブリとかゴキブリ目があるって言ったっけ
まあゴキブリよりも小さいいろいろ虫がいても
目がある場合はね 体と計算してみるとバカでかい目なんですよ
だからすごい小さい世界で生きてるでしょ
だから どのように見えてるんですかね
あの世界は だから私たちには見えないぐらいの小さな獲物を取って食べたりするしね
かなり大きく見えるでしょ
結局はね すりすりすると
ですから こうやってこの視力やらもうもう耳の力やらね
そういうのはもうそんなに当てにならないんです
まあとにかく感じたものなんですよ
だから感じた 感じた 感じたっていうことは事実であって
故にあるあるということは言えないんです
一般的には言う だから事実は感じたっていうことで
感じるためには ものは変化しなきゃ感じません
もしそちらに本棚があったならば
それはずっと変化しているはずなんです
その変化がの情報 なんらかの形で目に触れたとしますからね
で 目が変化する それを感じて
その変化を計算して 頭の中で本棚という幻覚を作るだけなんです
そういうことだから あの思考の勉強というか
思考の勉強じゃなくて
認識の勉強もあんまりにもまるっきりやってない
ただあるといきなり思ってしまっただけ
だから外に本棚があるんだから
本棚があると思う私がいると
だからあるということも浮いていて
ですから私がいるという言葉も浮いているんです
私が変化しなきゃあるわけあると知れませんだからね
だから全てのものは変化によって成り立つんですよ
変化がなければこの暖房がないんですよ
ずっと何か変化が起こしてるんですよ
だから暖房というんです
蛍光灯というためには
ずっと変化を起こしてくれなきゃ蛍光灯にならないんです
何か機能しないと 機能っていうのは変化なんですね
ですから そこで実体的な私があるということは
単なる人間の妄想概念に過ぎない
そこら辺は科学的な事実だから
実験してほしいんですよ
実験したところで自分がいるという実感がなくなって
それと同時に心の苦しみも消えちまうんです
だから そのためにこのサティということが必要なんですね
この感覚 感じるものは確認しておく
見えている 聞こえている
痛み 膨らんでいる 縮んでいるとかね
それはすごくつまらなく見えるんだけど
それは自分なんです 自分というものはそれだけなんです
何か妄想しているとか
それで妄想をよくよく見ると
どんな感覚で妄想しているんですかと
例えば嫌なことがあったりすると
それを覚えておいて それまた浮かんではくる
浮かんではくると 気持ちいいものがあったりしちゃうと
それまた覚えておいて
浮かんではくる 浮かんではくると
感覚でしょ 結局 結局ほとんど過去でしょ
過去に乗り越えたことなんか
浮かんでは妄想する 浮かんでは妄想すると
だから自分っていうのはそれぐらいのもので
そういうことだから このサティという実践方法で
この無明の闇を破ってしまうんだと
ちょっとで この実況中継してみるんですね
起こることを解釈したらそこで間違っちゃうんですね
解釈はなり方ないんです
あの この方向で仏教を理解するのは随分もう恐ろしく難しいんですよ
これは本当にこの あの
知識認識知恵に基ついて
お釈迦様がどのように見たかということなんです
だからこれは一般の人にはちょっともう消化できないぐらい難しい方向へちょっと喋ってしまっちゃったんだけどね
だから自分たちが瞑想の方で行った方がやりやすいんです
だからあると思ったっていうこと
あると思っただけなんです
目に 目に変化が起きたんですよ
同じ変化が起こったらいつでも本棚があると思うんです
あれを覚えているなら
必ず本棚ある必要はないんです
そこはまあわかりますか？例えばこの
昔 脳の研究した あれ あまり実際に研究をやってないんですけどね
脳のある一部を電気で刺激しちゃうと
音が聞こえたりする 喋ったりする
だから本当はこの脳のすべてわかっているように喋ってますけど
それほど研究できてないんです
難しいんだから でも昔
二 三回あったんですね
こういう病気の人が来たら
もうもういい加減研究してみたんですね
脳を 脳を開けて いろんなところを刺激して
その患者さんと喋ってみる
だから脳の 脳を開けても麻痺する必要ないんです
脳には神経ないんだから
痛みはないんだから ですから
まあそうやってあの 行くところで
やっぱりどこら辺か何かちょっと脳に刺激与えれば
まあ何か思い出す 喋り出すとかいろいろありますから
例えば麻薬取ったら幻覚見るでしょ
それは麻薬取ってない我々はそれを幻覚と言うんだけど
本人にとっては幻覚ではありませんね
で 一番簡単な例は テープレコーダー
テレビなんかは存在しないんですよ
脳に幻覚を起こさないと
だからここに人がいるという
一応仮定しますね そこでいるという
私は言うのは 目に変化が起こるんだからなんです
似ている変化が起こっちゃったら
あ その人やと言うんです
なんて写真見て あ これ田中さんだというでしょ
同じ 似ている 似ている変化が起きたんだからなんです
テープレコーダーから全然音は出てきません
例えば誰かもう歌ってる人がね
まあ有名人でも誰でもいいんだけど
もう あ これはもう もう三郎さんの歌ですよと
いいよ それ三郎さん歌ってないんですよ
そう なんとか三郎さんが歌っているということで作った
その音と 今のテープレコーダーが作っている音っていうのは似ています
似ていますから 同じ錯覚を目の中で
耳 頭の中で生まれるんです
いとも簡単にできるんです
で あの ラジオだけやった時は
ドラマなんかやってると
雪の音とか 風の音とか
全部作るでしょ 全部嘘でしょ
あれは 今もNHKに行ったら
そういう道具とかね 音を作るために使った道具とか展示してますからね
雪 雪の上で人が歩いているというと
何かの機械でその音を作って
で 後で まあいろいろ機械できたんだから
実際の音を録音して あの
記録ファイルを作って
それをつなげるということを今やったりしますけどね
昔はそうじゃないんですね
でも聞いてみたら全く似ていて
雨の音と 何か猿みたいなものに何か豆ほんのちょっと入れて
まあそうやったりこうやったりすると雨の音
故にこれが雨の音っていうことは結論できますかと
まあそういうことで まあ
まあ何か錯覚なんですけど
まあそれも概念で 雨の音っていうことは
まあ我々人間だけ使って
犬は何するかっていうか分かりませんし
まあそこでどう見たっても変化が必要なんです
変化がなければ音はなし
見えるものもない 目もない
だから見えるものは無常だから見えるんであって
目が無常だから見えるんである
ですから感覚も無常 当然
例えば今時計の音を聞いたでしょ
これは長い間音を聞かないと音だとわからないんです
ナノセカンド単位で見ちゃうと
ほんのちょっとほんのちょっとの音の音痴が耳に触れて触れて触れて
まとめて音と言うんだから
ですから 感覚も同じスピードで変化していくんです
だからそのスピードを科学的に全部計算しているでしょ
このいろいろ周波数やいろんなね
言葉で光の速度はこれぐらいとかね
例えば蛍光灯かなんか電気のスピードあるでしょ
megahertz とか megahertz
六十かな五十五かな 分かりません
一秒間で 五十万回変化するんですね
だから megahertz というのは
それぐらい速さで光が消えたり
消えたりと現れたり消えたり現れたりしてるんです
そこは目に触れて 目でもそれがもうずっと撮ってるんです
感覚もそれぐらいで変化するんです
もっと 例えば音が 音の聞こえる周波数あるんですね
それは超音波になっちゃうと聞こえないでしょ
現れて消えるって それがあまりにも早くて
それぐらい早く耳の感覚は変化しないんです
だから超音波は聞こえない
そこで低音も聞こえないでしょ
音はあるんだけど なぜかって耳の感覚はあまりにもノンビリ変化するんだから
音だと認識しないんです
そこで あの まあ私みたいに年取ってくると耳鳴りがあるんです
静かに自分のちょっと頭の中
そんな静かでないことあっても
ちょっと頭の中観察したところで
すごいキーという全然止まらないんです
その音 それだけ聞いちゃうと
もう頭が痛くなるほどうるさくて
もう我慢できないんだから
一応聞こえないようにしていますよ
みんな それだけ聞いちゃうと
もう頭が痛くなるほどうるさくて
もう我慢できないんだから
一応聞こえないようにしていますよ
みんな あの音どこにあるんですかね
どこにもないでしょ ただ神経が振動しているんです
それが音になっちゃうんです
まあですから この 聞こえる音あって聞こえない音とか
だから見える光があって見えない光もありますね
そういうのはごくごく普通の
まあ小学生の科学の知識でわかっていることだからね
だからこの体の感覚 反応を起こすかないか
変化するかしないか そこであるという概念が生まれてくる
だからある igual 変化なんです
そういうわけで 僕は徹底するんですよ
無常という概念に これはすごい智慧であって
もう遊びの概念じゃないんです
やっぱり無常だという
まあいい加減な言葉じゃないんです
存在すなわち無常 無常であるというわかった人はまあほっとするんですよ
別に困るなことっていうのはいいんだから
どうせ無常ですから 今ここに私がいないんだから
いろんなものを組み合わせて
ただ変化しているだけ
だから その巨大な智慧を発見するために
自分で自分の体をもって実験して
自分で確かめるために
この感覚を実況中継してみるんです
なぜ実況中継するかというと
解釈することをやめてもらいたいんです
今までの勉強した あのまるっきり嘘の勉強は
もうちょっと置いておいてほしいんです
ヒンドゥー教の宗教哲学も
仏教の哲学も もうヨーロッパの哲学も
全てちょっと置いておいてくださいと
あんなものは全てもう一応嘘だからね
だからこの考えるって
もう問題作っちゃいますから
ですから そこは一旦ストップ
それには実況中継とそう
すると考えられなくなっちゃうんです
かなり忙しくて それで感覚だけ実況中継して
それをサティと言うんですね
だからこの実践は 実践と言ったっていいし
実験と言ったっていいし
とっても簡単なんですよ
これほど簡単なことでわかるものは
この人類の中で誰一人も発見できないんだから
これ不思議なんです だから論理的に見ると
魂があると言っただけでもうアホでしょうに
あったら言うだから 聖書を開けたら
初めは言葉ありきと始まるでしょう
そこは説明する必要ないんだからという感じで
インド系だったら初めは暗闇があったとかね
いろんなもうそのその宗教の世界で
初めはなんとかあって
そこから出てきたんだと
証拠も何もなく ただそれはまず信じなさいよと
信じたところで これから話す話ならわかりますよと
当たり前のことでしょう
魂があるんだと それから魂は細長いと説明する
それはわかりますよ 例えば魂は無限であるという人々
いう人その例 目は本当に小さいでしょ
目はすごい小さいんですよし
目の中にある穴がもっと小さいんですね
目の目ん玉は大きくてでかいんだけど
小さな穴からでしょ 光が入る
それがすごいバカでかい空にいるんです
それで外にバカでかい無限の空があると思っちゃうと
これあると思うのは魂であるならば
魂っていうのは小さくて無限やと
という言葉を言えるんです
最初で最大ですよと それかっこいい言葉でしょ
我は最初で一番小さくて最大なものなりと
ちゃんとドネセズにありますよ
私が言ってることは 普通の人が一番小さくて一番大きいものって何なのかと
やっぱりわかりませんとかね
すごいことやとかね で
困ったりする 一番小さくて一番大きいのは魂なんです
で どうやってそういう知恵が得たって
そんな風なものなんです
でも 本当のところ 我々のバカでかい空は見えてないんです
大きさは脳が作るんです
脳の中には  情報はバラバラにして入るし
脳でその情報を組み立てる
だから脳に教えてあげれば違うように組み立てなさい
そのように組み立てますよ
日本人がご飯好きでヨーロッパ人がパン好きっていうのは
それ脳に組み立ててるんだから
そういうふうに思いなさいよ
ですから そういう脳が組み立てる知識も当てにならないんですね
とにかくその過程をわかるためには
この自分の感覚を単純に実況中継している
それにサティというんです
で 実況中継だけで だけでも何もわからなくなる可能性もあります
ですから サティと同時にサンパジャンニャということも必要なんです
このサンパジャンニャっていうのは目を覚ましておけってことなんです
目を覚めておいてないんですよ
だからまあ実況中継はするんだけど
何やってるかとわかってないんですね
あれ なかなか説明できない
定義もできない言葉なんですけど
この目覚めておくというふうなことなんですね
だから妄想すると寝ているんですよ
妄想しないと目が覚めているんです
[音楽]じゃあ目が覚めた具体的な例はないかねえか
何かこの何か石でも落ちて私の膝の上に落ちたとします
で そこで石の膝が痛い
痛くなる それでサティの世界では石が触れた
まあ触れた痛み そこで何かぶつかって痛みが生まれたと
ぶつかったことをわかっているんだから
まあこれ触れました 痛みが生まれた
それ実況中継するでしょ
それで終わっちゃうならば目が覚めてます
そちらに何の不思議なこともあるわけじゃない
ただ石がこちらに触れたんだ
触れた痛み で 寝ている辺ちは
なんで石が飛んできたんですか？とか
いろんなことを考えたりする
他の誰かに当たろうとする
だからその情報だけで止まって
実際の情報これだけですよ
だから暖房の前の例で
あの 一番最初にわかりませんと答えたでしょう
外の暖房ついてますか？と聞いたところでもわかりませんと
で その答えも正しいんですね
だから 空いてますかないかということは
目で確かめるものだったら
耳の音では確かめられないはずなんですね
だから耳に音が入っているだけですから
まあ音は音だけ まあ音ですと言うならば
そこでサティとサンパジャニャがあるんです
でも口でわかりませんと言っても
心ではやっぱり空いているんだと
もう知ってるんだからやっぱり飛んでいるんです
だから瞑想でその飛ぶところは止まってほしい
そこはサンパジャニャなんです
例えば時計の音を時計の音と確認すると
それほど鋭くないんですね
時計かどうかさっぱりわからない
ただ 音だけで確認できたところで
鋭いサンパジャニャがあるんです
それに訓練が必要なんですね
音が耳に入った途端 あ
車だと思っちゃうんですね
飛ぶんですよ 妄想 それは妄想なんです
サンパジャニャあったら
ものすごい早くもう悟りの方向に心を進んでいっちゃうんです
だから何かこちらの瞑想したら
何もわからないうちにやらせるところです
一日仏陀になってくると
すごい素晴らしく まあ真理の世界発見するんです
なんか私が説法を聞いてるような感じになるんですね
もうインタビューで私が喋るんじゃなくて
やっぱりこのいろんなものを頭にインプットしていない場合は
例えばそれだけやってみなさいと言ったら
すごい面白おかしく生まれて初めてやったみたいなところでびっくりして
こういうことか 生きるってのはと
すぐ発見する そういう人々がいます
すっごいもう伸びて伸びて伸びてくる人々がいます
解釈もする 解釈もするから言葉が伸びちゃうというかね
飛ぶ 的を外れて飛んじゃう
だからこれも頭の問題で
もう一つ何か先にあるんだと
頭の中にインプットしているんです
もう一つ先にあるんじゃなくて
それだけだと というふうなことで
知る世界はこれだけやってことで止まれるともう
終わりますけどね だからそれほど大したことないんです
知ることはそれにだけ止まってるんだから
私にとっては人間差別哲学で何でも持ってきてぶつけてみてください
すぐ説明してみせますから
これはこれで これはこれ
この人はこういうふうに考えたでしょうとか
だからもうこんな小さいんですよ
真理って その点でいうと
それを知ったらもう だからお釈迦様もまあまあ
それ知ったら全部知ってますよ
例えば昨日の質問で観音様のうんぬんって出たでしょ
で 全ての生命を救うためにわざと自分が輪廻に入らないという
というすごいありがたいという話で出てきて
そういう話はどのように発生しました？これは仏教の慈悲の概念なんですね
人を助ける 他人を助ける
それは大変な道徳なんですよ
ですから 立派な道徳なんですね
それでそれを人格化するんです
この抽象的な言葉 慈しみっていうのは
別にどこかあるわけじゃないんです
慈しみっていうのは 我々がやっている行為に使うラベルだけなんですね
私は人を殴っちゃうと
それはもう暴力で悪いことだと
その人を慰めてあげれば慈しみだというラベルだけなんですよ
そこで愛を人格化すると
怒りを人格化すると そうやって人間の感情を人格化するということは
これは仏教だけじゃなくて
ギリシャ物語あれも同じですよ
美を人格化してビーナスかあれはね
えっと 戦いは人格化してなんとか神がいますね
あの それです ギリシャ物語で
え？うん マーズ 太陽は人格化して
ジュピターとかいろいろ
ハルキウリスは地球を背負っているとかいうの
で そうやって嫉妬も憎しみも人間の欲も人格化して
性的な欲もね それはエロスですね
同じエロスということは欲に使っています
それでストーリーを作るんですね
そこでお釈迦様は全部それを壊しちゃったでしょ？今まで面白いストーリーを聞いて楽しがっていたのに
みんな おとぎ話を聞きながら
なんかインドの世界でもね
インドの世界でも腐るほど神々がいるんですね
猿も神で牛も神ですから
ネズミも神なんです だからあれ
病気がありますね あれペスト？殺せません
なぜかというと 智慧の神様が
神様の乗り物はネズミなんです
えらい頭がいい神様なんです
だからネズミに乗ってる
だからもう殺せません
ネズミを殺す権利あるのは一つのカーストの人々だけ
他の人は殺せません それでペストになったり
病気になったりしますけど
まぁとにかくまぁ神々がいっぱいいたんですね
全て人間が勝手に作った戦争の神や
さぁ そこはもう壊れてしまっちゃったんだから
仏教の人々はこのヒンドゥー教で消えた神々の代わりに新しい神々を誕生させるんです
だから慈しみは観音で
智慧は？文殊で 富豪はなんでしたっけ
うん 精進かなんとかですね
そうやって菩薩作っちゃうんです
そのものが本当にいるんですか？と聞きたくなりますね
そこでいるという人々は韓国にはいます
観音はいると なぜかというと
この観音乗り移っちゃうんです
韓国にこの観音道場が有名なところがありまして
そちらに行ってみんなもう手を上げてお祈りして
一丁一丁儀式儀式やっちゃって
乗り移っちゃって もう観音みたいにハスの花で持ってこられて踊ったりすると
あ 多様だなと思ったりもする
そういうのは何の根拠もないんです
単なる自己暗示しか何もないんですね
乗り移ることで神は存在するんだっていうことが勘違いしている人々が
このとにかく脳をおかしくしないと
脳細胞を麻痺しないと
麻痺したところでやりやすいです
だから そういう神が宿っているという
まあまあ言葉だけではジンチャという言葉ですけど
そちらはまず部屋が小さい
窓はない 空気は回らない
部屋 ドア一つしかない
その中に大勢の人が集まる
それでいっぱい灯り それからもう線香いっぱい焚く
インドだったら薬草を焚いちゃいます
あれ麻薬ですけどね 麻薬使うのはもう遠い昔
四千年前からやっていたんです
神にお祈りする時は飲む特別な飲み物があります
ソウマと言うんです それは
あれは純粋な酒でもなくて
なんとなくこのいろいろ葉っぱで作るこの幻覚を起こす飲み物なんですね
キノコとかいろいろありますけどね
ああいう場所で灯りをいっぱい焚くと
また酸素がね 人がいっぱい入っちゃうとものすごいもう酸素消えちゃう
それで線香もその上足す
そこで止まるんじゃないんですよ
チャランチャランチャランでいっぱい音を鳴らす
そこでも止まりません
まあバカでかい声で神に追い出す
サンケツ法で それまた節もそれなりにも決まっていて
で そこら辺で気持ち悪くなって
頭を振って投げます で
神が抜ける 時々あの永久的に脳がダメージ受ける場合もあります
サンケツっていうのはそんなもう遊びじゃないんだから
このサンケツ状態で脳がものすごい幻覚作るんです
麻原もやったのはそういうやり方なんです
この麻原のあの従順者たち
解脱者たちがみんなこの生きたサンケツ状態を体験しているんです
だからみんな悟れない
で あの永久的な脳にダメージ受けちゃうと
なかなか治ることもできないんですね
脳が壊れちゃうとね そういうこともあります
ですから ただ単に誰かに神が乗り移ったんだからといって
何か変なことしたっても
それでもってその神が存在するっていう証拠にならないんです
そういうこの世界っていうのは
まあかなり学問的には分析しています
その神秘体験ってどういうどういうものか
それは明確に分析しているんです
そんな不思議なことでもない
あまりにも世界広いんだから
もうこれはどこまで喋ったってキリがないんだから
一応基本的には人間はこの
そうやって神を人間が作る
だから仏教から見ればいい
美味しいなのはみんな慈しみを実践しなさいよと
人に優しくしなさいよ
それはあなたにとってはいいことになりますよ
それをやらないで神に仕立てて拝むと
知恵っていうのはあなたがあなたの阿呆だから頑張って知恵を開発しなさいということですよ
それをやらないで 普賢という神を作って拝むと
拝んで御利益をちょうだい
知恵をちょうだい インドでガネーシュという神様のところに行って
ラクシュミという女神のところに行って同じことを願ってますからね
知恵をちょうだいと まあ説明してたのは
この認識のシステムね
からくりを理解したら
人が言うことは人も簡単に理解できるんですね
哲学であろうが何であろうが
宗教で言っていることとか悩むことはなくなっちゃうんです
裁判はもうなんか物質現象化しているんだから
物質化しているんだから
どうかなとかね なんかあるんじゃないかと
そういう悩みなんかはもう消えちゃうんです
どこかのなんとか瞑想法でこうこうなったんだから
例えばもう麻原のグループの連中もね
我々はこういう経験しているんだから
みんなまあそうかもっていう感じでいるでしょうね
本当にこの構成 この認識のからくりを知ったならば
もう何のことかなとわかるんです
悩むことなくなっちゃう
疑がすべて晴れるんです
これっていう疑が残らない
そこで 人間のすべての苦しみのすべての問題の出てくるのは
この自分がいるんだっていう考え方からだ
それはどうだ 自分がいるんだっていうことは研究しません
それを認めて 上 どんな自分かと考える
不幸な自分か 幸せな自分か
なんだかいろいろ 自分がいるんだと思っちゃうと
真相をあげたくないっていうことにもなる
死にたくないともなる
財産が絶頂だっても この連中に財産は残したくないとかね
そういう気持ちにもなる
そこで心っていうのは
この妄想 この目っていうのは目が壊れたら見えませんですけど
耳はもうなんかちょっとでもおかしくなっちゃったら聞こえなくなっちゃいますけど
心っていうのは途切れなく回転するんです
何もなくても回転する
だからそこに自分 心の自分がいるんだっていうことはありますから
だからまあ死んじゃっても
その回転続けてしまっちゃうんです
でも面白いことじゃないんですよね
輪廻転生っていうのは
ろくも大変なことなんです
だからみんな間違ってる言葉がある
輪廻転生っていうのは
まあ仏教で一応一般的には言ってますけど
それで認めていると勘違いしてるんです
だからありがたい だからありがたいではなくて
だから怖いと ということを言いたがってるんです
輪廻転生するなと言ってることだからね
輪廻転生という概念を看板で持っていって
そこで仏教を広めるということをやってるわけじゃないんです
これをやめろと 無意味だと
今の人生は無意味ですから
死んでどこかで生まれたって同じことでしょう
大体自分ですよという実感さえあればいいんだけど
それもないでしょ 今我々は例えば過去でどこかでいた生命だとするならば
今の我々の幸せであろうか
幸福であろうか 不幸であろうか
それ過去でいたその生命がやったことの結果でしょう
全然知らないんです 例えば今幸せだとする
過去で誰かさんがね 苦労して苦労していいことをして
それで我々はこんな形をとって
それの結果味わってるんですね
だからなんかもう そういうことであまり意味がないんです
だから実際の輪廻の 死んでからのどうやって心が働くかっていうこと
説明できればいいんだけどね
これはちょっとまた同じく人間に理解できないほどちょっと幅広すぎなんです
でもきちんとした科学的に説明できますけど
あの前の説明でもちょっと難しかったでしょ
このものがあるというの説明
あれは一応理解できることなんですけど
ですから あの あまり私を責めてもね
説明できないんです 難しくて
あまり面白いものでもないし
まあそういうことで とにかくこのね
サティでもって一応情報の確認する
ことだけする そこで今自分が何を確認したかっていうことはしっかりしては解釈しない
痛みですと眠気ですと
まあ夜ちょっと睡眠不足で
だから睡眠が そういうのは余計なんです
それもうサンパジャンニャがないんです
そこまで言えば 過去に行かないこと
将来に行かないで 今自分
今の自分とってる具体的にとっているデータだけで留まることでサンパジャンニャないんですね
そうすると この因果法則によって物事をどうやって生まれて消えていくかっていうことが見えてくる
だからたくさんヴィパッサナー瞑想していても成長ない人ってのはこのサンパジャンニャないんですね
やっぱりこの心が変に働いてるんですね
先を考えるか 過去の何かに行くか
何かで解釈するか 何とかやっちゃう
ですから このどうしても解釈しちゃうんだったら
お釈迦様が言うのは お釈迦様はそこで
あの どうしても妄想するんだったら
やめたくないんだったら
妄想は どうも解釈したいと思うならば
お釈迦様はおっしゃってるんですよ
解釈は 確認しながら やっぱり無常だ
やっぱり消えた やっぱり新しい経験だとか
痛みがあった 消えた その痛みが消えた
また痛みが出ていることでしょう
また痛みが出たと思ったところで
過去の痛みが出たと思っちゃうんですね
そこを間違ってるんです
無常だと あの痛みは消えた
今あるのは別な痛みです
新しい痛みなんです それ新しい痛みです
それも無常だから消えると
もう消えたって無常だから
また他の痛み 新しい痛みが生まれるんだと
瞑想 ちょっと調子 調子が良くてうまくいったと思ったっても
今はうまくいってるんだ
故にずっとこれからうまくいけば
これはもうそんなことないし
無常だからね 次にどうなるかわからないんだ
そうやって無常に基づいて思考を働かせてみる
例えばみんなずっと瞑想していて
もうまだかまだか もう時が止まっているかとかね
まあ悩んだりする もうイライラして
そこでちゃんとおりんの音を聞いた瞬間で見てください
自分の心の変化っていうのを
生まれ変わったような心が変わるでしょう
だから泣いてる人を笑わせるためにはそんな時間かからないでしょう
笑ってるを泣かせるためにも
それほど時間かからないでしょうに
人を怒らせるためにも
一秒二秒でもできるでしょうに
自分は早く全て変化していくんです
ですから この無常の方向へ
何一つも一定していない
同じものではない 瞬間でも同じではない
それは自分というものなんです
おかしいのは 今苛立っているのは自分じゃないと思うところなんです
本当は清らかな立派な自分がいるんだと
苛立ちが別なものやと思うところなんです
怒ってはいけませんと思っちゃうと
清らかな自分がいて 怒りは何か別なものやと思うところなんです
でも 怒っている自分は自分であって
怒ってない自分も自分である
その瞬間 その瞬間変わっちゃうんです
そういう風に あの 無常であるという方向へ考え方を持っていく
変わるのは当たり前だ
そうすると瞑想もしやすくなると思います
だから この探している瞑想の成長と我々が希望している瞑想の成長は違う
結構違うんです 我々希望しているのは智慧の開発であって
真理の発見であって あんたもう 1週間もやったんだから
もうもう 1人前で元気に瞑想できますよ
そんな話じゃないんです
私たちが希望する方向で瞑想を進んだら
それはすごくわかります
その人のは大体鋭い かなり鋭く失敗もしない
物事にあまりこのうようよしたりとかね
もう悩んだりとかね くよくよしたりもしない
すぐ何か問題出たら すぐそこにはあ
こういうこと すぐインスピレーションが出てくる
性格は必ずしも変わる
瞑想して私たち希望する方向へ成功している
ただ もう何時間でも座っているんだとかね
身を張って頑張っているんだということで
別にあまりあまり感動はしませんけど
まあ真面目に頑張っているところは真面目に真剣にしているのはわかりますけども
鋭くなるはずなんです
じゃあ 一応頑張ってください
どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございます